in today's eye on money stock markets
got a major boost
from the promising covet vaccine news
and
the prospect of divided government in
washington the dow soared more than 800
points yesterday
or nearly 3 percent to its highest close
since february
pfizer's stock surged more than seven
and a half percent which i had some of
that
the pharmaceutical giant and its german
partner biontech
said their experimented experimental
coveted vaccine
is more than 90 percent effective cbs
news business analyst jill sles
jill schlesinger joins us now jill is
the market reaction premature do you
think considering that this vaccine
is still a ways off well i think that
investors are really
looking past the exact timing of when
this will be
widely adopted and accepted as a vaccine
because really it doesn't matter
to them whether it's three months or six
months it really matters that there's
optimism
that consumers and businesses will get
back to their usual ways of spending
i think that that reaction on the pfizer
stock may have been a little overdone i
mean this is a massive company one
vaccine
is not going to change its fortunes by
seven and a half or even
eight percent but again many times
markets overreact to both the upside and
the downside
how much do the election results factor
into the the market search joel
you know last week we had a huge week
for stocks
in fact it was the best election week
since 1932.
sentiment really became very happy
with the idea of a democratic president
a republican-controlled senate
a democratic house because the idea here
would be
well a biden presidency with the split
chambers
would not be able to enact new taxes on
either
corporations or the wealthiest 2 percent
of americans
it would not be able to do a huge
spending bill like a green new deal
and probably would have a somewhat
steadier less mercurial hand when it
comes to
the china trade policy so what if you've
about 55 percent of americans according
to a gallup poll i think are invested in
the market what would you tell people to
do right now
remember way back when in march where
you were pulling your hair out
freaking out that markets were plunging
and at that time i came on and i said
please do nothing
i am asking you to do the exact same
thing to really tamp down those emotions
here's what we have learned since march
it is very difficult to predict
the short-term movements of markets
market timing
does not work time in the market does
work don't worry about the next four
days the next
four weeks the next four years you are a
long-term investor
you are investing for decades in the
future so
stick to your game plan you've got to
keep cool so where
where do you think the economy stands
now relative to the pandemic
how much pressure is the pandemic still
putting on this economy
i think we're still under pressure but
the data have been good we have recouped
about
two-thirds of the economic losses that
we saw
back in march and april and that's great
news
and when we look at march and april time
horizon remember there were 22 million
jobs just vanished we've gotten back
more than half of those
and here's the but unfortunately we
still have an economy that's about
three and a half percent smaller than it
was at the end of last year
and we still have about 10 million fewer
jobs than we had
before the pandemic so there is still a
critical
need to focus on the economy to control
the virus
and allow the economy to get back to its
better self we haven't gotten a new
injection of stimulus money jill do you
think that is something we really still
need
i think we absolutely need it you know
when i speak to economists they say
we're in this very strange
in-between period right now as i said
the economy has been improving
but think about it the surge of virus it
is absolutely
apparent that that is causing consumers
and businesses to pull back a little bit
we have municipalities that are clamping
down on some of their
reopening efforts and so the time
between
right now and the time between this
vaccine could be widely available and
adopted
is critical people will need help we
know that
individuals will need help helping them
getting through this period with extra
unemployment with extended benefits
with relief from eviction potential and
foreclosures
this is really something that's terribly
important you know just recently goldman
sachs actually put out a note that said
more than half of small business owners
are not paying themselves
and four in ten have said they've
already started laying off people
because they cannot get their businesses
back to their previous conditions fast
enough
it's been a real struggle all right jill
schlesinger thank you jill